there's nothing riskier than uh
then i don't think fighting for your
life man
and that's what um that's what our next
guest does and
and uh he's one of a kind and um
he is uh he has been the uh
the interim lightweight champion and
yeah we're gonna give uh get him uh on a
zoom call in just a moment
should i put on some uh
cologne i thought you're gonna say
cologne i mean that's cool
curve in the background
dustin the diamond poirier man good to
see you bro
good to see you too man i like that
chain oh thank you very much bro that's
that old carnival chain baby
yeah buddy pick the animal on the wall
yeah yeah
i picked that chain baby how you feeling
today good
good yeah man i just uh got home about
an hour or so ago and
eight got a good wrestling practice in
this morning man i'm grinding
nice man uh did i saw you uh the ufc
putting your tweets up and stuff the
other night during the fight
uh how did it feel to be watching fights
again man it felt good it
freaking motivated me dude it motivated
me so much i uh
woke up the next day with a different
pep in my step you know i'm i want to
fight and i want to
i want to show the world what i can do
man when you were watching the fights
was there any part during the fights
you're like
where without the crowd being there
you're like wow that must have been
totally different or
what are some things that kind of stood
out to you that were either surprising
or
even humorous even uh
i was surprised at how how patient and
uh calculated gait she was when he had
tony hurt a few times
you know i think the geichi of old would
have just ran in
uh threw cosh to the wind and tried to
finish him and maybe got hurt himself
but
he was very composed um i'm not sure if
that had anything to do with the crowd
not being there maybe he's the guy who
feeds off the crowd
ah you know um yeah because if the
crowd's going nuts and you might just
follow their lead
yeah just angry bird in there yeah
but uh you know he he had a great
performance dude
showed a lot of growth in since his last
few fights and uh you know hats off to
him he's the man
yeah you called that fight i saw um what
made you going into that when you're
like oh i i feel like he's got this
i just thought that tony makes a lot of
mistakes and
um i didn't think the fight was going to
go to the ground i thought it was going
to be a stand-up fight which it was
uh i just you know tony's been hurt in a
lot of fights he he's
tony actually surprising man he's way
more durable than i thought he was wow
he's been dropped by pettis um lando
venata
a few guys he's been hurt by he gets
hurt in almost every fight
yeah but incredible durability man
what a warrior would
was uh was there any moment in the fight
was there any moment in a fight where
like does a fight ever get going so good
when you wish you were in it or
or the fight going so good where you're
like oh man i'm glad i'm not in that
no i like that type of stuff of course i
don't want to
get my brain beat up but when fights
like the gaechi tony fight
is happening that was kind of more
one-way traffic but it was a great fight
yeah um during those type of fights i
just
you know i always go to sleep after
watching those fights and just pray that
i get a chance to to be in one of those
type of fights and show the world
you know my grit and um
my fortitude in there they know when i
watch fights like that i i just want to
be part of that violence man
wow that is a total opposite how i feel
i will tell you this though man i was
very surprised uh with the charles rosa
fight
with your buddy yeah because you know
charles i trained with charles and he
has good jiu jitsu and he completely got
shut down you know
like uh oh with the yeah because you
guys work with american top team right
yeah yeah and you know i've been
training with charles probably since
2012 i've been rolling with him and
training alongside him wow and he does
have very high he does have very high
level jitsu
do you think he was just shocked do you
think that he i mean i think everybody
was kind of shocked that bryce was able
to pull off that type of
uh you know just i mean he turned in
almost just like a cricket you know like
i mean he was just
you know he was just right there oh dude
he was sunken in
yeah i think uh what really surprised
rosa i think is uh bryce's top pressure
just his control on top
and uh being able to continue to get
charles down like that
um that was that i was surprised man i
was really surprised in that fight
yeah yeah it was an exciting night of
fights well dude i i'm so excited for
you man thanks for jumping on i just
wanted to kind of touch base and just
kind of see what you were thinking after
the fight man
uh obviously you really enjoyed it was
there what was the biggest surprise for
you of the evening you think
honestly the biggest surprise was was uh
tony's durability
because he got hit clean often
and uh you know he absorbed most of it i
believe in the final
few punches that he kind of turned away
and the ref stopped it i think the ref
knew something was wrong with tony
and obviously there was so great
stoppages orbital was broken if they
would have continued to fight you know
the broken orbital could cause you to go
blind and a lot of bad things can happen
if you get hit while your you know
structure your face is broken so
great job by the ref and uh but but i
was really surprised at tony's
durability man i didn't
i didn't think he he was that durable at
all um
would you have stopped that uh would you
have stopped the cruz cejudo fight
that's tough because i thought cruz was
you know building up i thought he was
starting to
and there was only a few seconds left in
the round yeah and it's a world title
fight
you know man of course on this side as a
fighter
i i want to let me go out you know i
know what i signed up for i know what
i'm walking in there to do i know the
dangers
yeah let me go out all the way so we
know the fight's over
um and i feel like cruz was kind of
robbed of that opportunity to to be put
all the way out
and uh or to get up and and continue
fighting
yeah you gotta let it play out you gotta
good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one
watch this one watch this one watch is
one
ah